[Music]
hey everybody I'm here with videogame
megastar PewDiePie and he has a new show
coming out new series called scare
PewDiePie that's on YouTube red so make
sure you check that out the game we're
gonna play tonight is Far Cry primal
most video games take place in a dark
future that's fair this one seems to
take place a long time ago in the past
okay now it's 2016 but we're going back
in time at this speed we're gonna be
here for 40 hours they better pick it up
fast we just got to the birth of Larry
King and sorry you understood what I was
talking about good BAE
here we go when Jeff our blood people
this is their version of television he's
watching friends oh look at that he just
woke up with his sex toy that guy needs
moisturizer skin is coming off that's my
fear you were so close to shoving that
up that your friend's ass the goal of
the game that's foreplay in 10,000 BC
okay
where should I get a heart go for the
heart you're just poking them in the ass
oh my god all right I think those two
are in a relationship
what are you doing I'm clicking buttons
oh no not my friend this is when you say
you know what I've got puka shells I'm
good great time to turn down a gift I
don't see those clap I'm not a jewelry
guy but thank you okay so now we're on
the glacier and now you have a beast
week that can attack here all the beasts
that you've tamed I've tamed all those
beats badger get the patch where's the
badger go let hyah badger actually
you're about to beat you're about to be
attacked we're on the left oh they're
gonna warn me
[Applause]
a fire a weapon why do i oh yeah poison
hold the left treat there you go that
was awful he started to it turn into a
high five and it just fell apart it was
I never want to do that again I love
that badger he needs a name
what's a good name PewDiePie you know
good names you could use a great Swedish
name Thanks
faint yes just rolls up and down it
sounds like you dropped a battery down
the toilet he's here here and that's the
guy's penis a field day free disgusting
bad oh they just heard what the Badger
did they ran away we're gonna go up and
now you're gonna attack the camp I think
you should do the AL what do I do
bomb the Shannon I just released the
white owl and you're getting them all
I didn't know I'm trying to do you're
doing it see you ah we're bombing is he
just what are you gonna land the wall
again no guys jeez I'm brand new to
being an owl
oh nice zoom badger once again
mutilating a corpse
such a pretty badger you ate 10 minutes
ago
booty pie is now going to attempt to
ride a mammoth yeah get it oh yes top of
the mammoth you just jumped on a wild
beast and you can control its motion
immediately you know what you're on
you're on the prehistoric uber you might
be inside oh my god it's like you're
having sex with Ed Asner sorry sleeping
oh he's looking at you he's like you're
an [ __ ]
if you like this video for some reason
click here to watch more click on his
face
that's a ringing endorsement beautify I
know how to say you like what just
happened you could have more I like that
yeah yeah good enough yeah go get it